he was the Lord of Dragonstone one of a
succession after the after the Targaryen
is fled valaria and settled on
Dragonstone in advance of the doom a
number of them came and went mostly
their eyes still gazed east toward esos
but as the years pass and son succeeded
father and brother succeeded brother
they began to take more interest in the
affairs of Westeros and Aegon finally
decided to take over Westeros and unify
the Seven Kingdoms that existed at a
time under a single rule there is a lot
of speculation that in some sense he saw
what was coming
300 years later and wanted to unify the
Seven Kingdoms to be better prepared for
the threat that he eventually saw coming
from the north the threat that we're
dealing with in assault of Ice and Fire
hey everybody its Charlie so if you
didn't catch that george RR martin just
revealed that Aegon Targaryen Aegon the
conquerer knew about the White Walkers
it implies that that's the true reason
why he conquered the Seven Kingdoms so
we got to break it down there's a new
round of that fire and blood book
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video the reason why he's dropping
all these big knowledge bombs is because
the fire and blood book is coming out so
he's talking about the Targaryen Kings
and even though a little bit of it will
cover a Gon's reign it mostly begins
with his sons maegor the cruel and
Annie's Targaryen but the cool thing
about this the idea that he wanted to
rally the realm sort of ties in with
what Jon Snow also named Aegon Targaryen
was doing during season seven and we
know you've been talking about the
slogan that they released with that last
big trailer for the throne the slogan
for season seven was rally the realm
that was Jon Snow's whole thing through
season seven was trying to get Daenerys
to realize the threat and join forces
with him then them both going to Cersei
in trying to get her to join forces with
them unsuccessfully of course but the
thing about the way George R Martin
talks about Aegon Targaryen makes him
sound like the way he says that
something terrible was coming makes him
sound a lot like the way he talks about
Rhaegar Targaryen in the books so we
actually do know a lot about how Rhaegar
was obsessed with prophecy and all the
things he did in pursuit of that even
though we know he loved Leone a stark
the books talked a lot about how he was
obsessed and felt like she was the
fulfillment of the prophecy or through
her they would bring about the
fulfillment of the prophecy in Jon Snow
a Song of Ice and Fire you also remember
the dannis the dreamer is the Targaryen
that had visions of the future that
allowed the original Targaryens that
flooded Dragonstone to escape the doom
so you have to remember that Aegon is
many generations removed from those
Targaryens he grew up on Dragonstone and
we don't know a whole lot about his
early life only that he traveled all
over Westeros balerion the black dread
was his dragon so even though this was
the time of the seven different kingdoms
and you have a lot of petty kings that
are all powerful in their own domains
he's still a Crown Prince of Dragonstone
they're still very powerful because of
their dragons so there's really no place
in Westeros that he can't go so as a
young man long before he decided to
conquer Westeros he was traveling all
over
place like a normal noble would for
political reasons diplomatic reasons we
don't know if he ever visited the wall
or flew his dragon and north of the wall
many years after Aegon had died there
was a later Targaryen queen that tried
to fly her dragons north of the wall
called queen alicent she said that her
dragon would keep turning back every
time she tried to fly north of the wall
the dragon would turn around and refuse
her which is a very unusual thing for a
dragon to do to a Targaryen that it's
bonded to dragons still have a will of
their own a dragon is not a slave like
they say during the series but they're
still very compliant to the Targaryens
that they're bonded to so it would have
to be a very serious matter for them to
refuse you but whether Aegon inherited
some of Daenerys ability to dream into
the future on a low level there are only
a couple of ways that Aegon could have
sensed what was coming in the White
Walkers so the wall had existed for a
long time wall was built between eight
and ten thousand years ago Aegon was
alive 300 plus years ago so the wall had
stood for eons by the time that Aegon
came along so he would have known about
the Nights Watch but you have to imagine
that the kings at that time didn't spend
a lot of time going to the wall they
still had the custom of allowing people
to take the black if they were convicted
criminals or if they were a lowborn
noble that felt like they had no claim
or no place in their family down in the
south but it had been so long since
there had been any real conflict up in
the north that people had slowly started
to forget about it like it became less
and less of a thing
the Nights Watch got smaller and smaller
the castles had been degrading for a
long time until we were left with only
the three manned ones that we have now
the one in the West the shadow tower
Castle black in the middle that we spend
most of our time out and then
eastwatch-by-the-sea that we just
watched get destroyed so there was any
threat that was being discussed north of
the wall around Aegon's time it was just
the threat of the wildlings and they
weren't even viewed as that big of a
threat at the time but it is always
possible that Aegon tried to fly
balerion the black dread north of the
wall to at least try and see if
something was happening the lands of
always winter are so far north from the
wall though that he would really have to
travel into the forest to get any sense
for them in around Aegon's time just
based on the way people talk about White
Walkers it sounds like they were still
relatively self-contained to that
Northwest area and the lands of always
winter so at the time the stories of
White Walkers north of the wall were
probably few and far
between but like we say Aegon as a young
man traveled all over the Seven Kingdoms
that's part of the reason why he
commissioned the map table of Westeros
be built that was long before he ever
decided to conquer the realm you could
say maybe he had aspirations to do that
someday but the original reason for
building it was purely for informational
purposes so the cool thing is though is
that he travels around he would have
access as a Crown Prince of Dragonstone
to any records that he wanted in the
Citadel
so the actual Citadel predates the doom
of Valyria they actually say that
maesters and arch maesters when they
couldn't find information that they
needed in Westeros would travel to the
Valyrian freehold to find what they
sought so before the doom of Valyria you
have to imagine that the Citadel was
probably full of books on dragon lore
and things from that time now they
didn't have a whole lot of records from
the long night because the Citadel
wasn't built and the maester order
wasn't found until many years after the
original long nights so records would be
spotty from that time but they would
probably have something they sort of
addressed that during season seven
through Samwell storyline where he is
looking at the forbidden section they
imply that there's all kinds of
information from that period that's
either been lost mostly just because
people haven't looked for it in a long
time but it's in there somewhere
the other really big problem too is that
records from the original long night and
even predating the doom of Valyria would
be many thousands of years old so if you
actually tried to read a scroll from
that period it would probably
disintegrate in your hands but as a
crown prince like Rhaegar many years
after him
Aegon would also have access to any of
the Citadel records that he wanted so if
he sent something was coming in wanted
to search for information about it the
Citadel they wouldn't be able to refuse
him even in present day tyrion talks
about spending a lot of time at the
Citadel reading through ancient tomes so
if you're a highborn Noble regardless of
which area you live in you have access
to pretty much any kind of information
that you want to but just remember when
the Citadel was created when they would
start keeping all this information and
the idea that Targaryen zhh have like
this low-level ability to sense the
future that they can pass down
genetically through generations so even
if Rhaegar and Aegon didn't have the
straight-up visions like Daenerys does
during the house of the end
and Anna's the dreamer did back before
the doom of Valyria they would still
have this low-level spidey sense that
something really terrible is coming but
I think the unfortunate thing on the TV
show is is that even though Jon Snow
genetically even though that could have
been passed down to him they haven't
really addressed that and because he's
with Daenerys and Daenerys already had
her visions they're doing most of that
story through her character but now it
makes a little more sense why Rhaegar
would want to name Jon Snow Aegon
Targaryen after Aegon the conquerer
because of the cyclical idea that they
foresees some danger that's coming it is
somehow they're the last hope for the
realm like during Aegon's time he felt
like he was the only person that could
unite the realm Jon Snow Aegon Targaryen
in present day feels like they're the
only people that can unite the realm
because this big threat is coming winter
is here probably would have been a
better slogan for season eight than for
the throne I've already done a video
about that and how it's a little bit of
smoke signals to throw you off the scent
for what's really going to be happening
towards the end of the series so I'll
link that at the end of this but let me
know in the comments what do you think
about this knowledge bomb that George
Armand dropped that Aegon Targaryen
really conquered the Seven Kingdoms
because of the same reason why Jon Snow
in present-day Aegon Targaryen is trying
to unite the realm it definitely shows
up the plot quite a bit putting a bow on
it congratulations Bryan a Jim you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Game of Thrones video please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your contact details click here for
that Game of Thrones season 8 trailer
that HBO just dropped and click here for
my Game of Thrones season 8 episode 1
preview thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome see you guys
tonight